After sorting our 27 data values, how do we know that the median was the 14th
value besides by simply counting? Is there a way we can describe the median
value in symbols? Let's start first by going over some symbolic notation that
we briefly mentioned earlier. Remember that these are the rankings, these are
not the actual data values, but we can denote the actual value in terms of its
rank. So, the value in the first rank would be X sub 1, then X sub 2 for the
second rank. X sub 3 for the third, and in the case of Udasiyans Facebook
friends, X sub 14 is the median. And remember that any value we can generically
denote X sub i where X sub i is the ith value. Yes, we do say ith. So what
about for any data set with n values? The median will be different depending on
whether or not n is even or odd. Now, this is going to be a really tricky quiz.
Which formulas describe the median after sorting the data? There's only one
answer for n even and one answer for n odd. Now, really quick, this might look
daunting, but just remember that this subscript part corresponds to the rank.
So, for example, say there are four values in the data set, n divided by 2
means 4 divided by 2 which is 2. So this would mean X sub 2, which is the
second value might be the median if n is 4. I'm not saying that's right, I'm
just giving you an example. So give this your best short. And again, this
should really help get you used to using symbols.